pourtant dieu sait que j'ai écrit sur
l'accent bric ils disent une sorte à
leur vie privée le snowdon et tout mais
je veux dire je pense qu'on confond deux
choses on confond la question qu'on
passe quand même pas le même mot qui est
surveillance pour les choses très
différentes et que la question des pas
la surveillance la question c'est
l'appareil répressif d'état en vérité si
vous êtes survie qu'il n'y a pas de
contrainte
il n'y a pas de sanction par rapport à
ce que vous faites aller vite ça n'a
aucune importance
et pour moi la question reste quand même
la question de l'appareil répressif de
la lys des petits de la prison et c'est
partir du moment où vous avez une
application pardon moi franchement je le
dis je suis très à droite
moi j'ai une application sur mon
téléphone quitter son job et je suis
contaminé les gens avec qui j'étais en
eau potable dans lesquels des régions
reçoivent une alerte sur leur portable
en visant à les contaminés restez chez
vous voyez pas votre grand mère ou un
âne et qui seraient en surpoids pendant
14 jours étant de faire attention
franchement s'il n'ya pas d'après aussi
des raisons mais pas en prison si jamais
j'ai fait ça donc deux choses nous aussi
on va pas transformer 50 de qualité
individuelle comme il faut toujours se
battre avec cette épidémie peut être on
y reviendra mais la question de parts
qui transforme et les épidémies en
termes de choix individuels de
responsabilité individuelle dans nos
politiques globales et de gestion de
groupe
actuellement il n'y a pas ces appareils
étaient précises pour moi c'est une
offensive
c'est à dire la question c'est la
répression c'est la contrainte d'état
c'est pas que il ya des instruments
technologiques qu'ils soient utilisés
pour prévenir une épidémie il ya un
fétichisme des mots comme surveillance
le flic à jeter livre sur nova savoir où
on se déplace franchement moi je suis
posé assez infantile même plus que ça et
un très beau jean lassalle je pars gens
qu'ils aient toujours moi je le bats
pour la transporte au combat pour la
justice
l'objectif de la justice mais gare à un
instrument a au moins donné que la
transparence donc je suis pas la
transparence mais il ya d'autres buts
pour obturer la justice je les
utiliserai donc il faut pas fétichisé le
moyen il faut ce qu'il faut réaliser la
fin si jamais par un certain type de
l'équipe technique on aboutit à une
diminution des morts décontamination de
la protection de la vie des gens
franchement je vois pas du tout du tout
moi personnellement ou les soucis du
moment que c'est bien pensé que ce n'est
pas lié à l'appareil
[Musique]